bring in customers what will there's
gonna be some changes around here
is every win and everyone who shows up
with a mouthful of clams well I was
thinking more along the lines of live
entertainment no wait not talent show
with your host been dreaming of mr.
Krabs you will be responsible for
bringing culture to this cultural
wasteland we call bikini bottom
[Music]
all right listen up people listen up
gather around everyone
shut up now you may be thinking this is
your one shot at the big time well it's
not it's mine hey squid how about this
for the show the amazing mr. absorbency
[Music]
no one I'm gonna want to see you in
gorge yourself so you really want to be
in the show okay you get the mop up
afterwards now will you stop bugging me
[Music]
listen what do you think when I mop
should I go forward and back
no no way side to side now poetry by
Gary come on
hurry up we're not gonna have enough
time for the backpack me mate
should I use Crysta cleanser or glad to
clean yes
the amazing plankton with the use of
Christie digitation will make a krabby
patty disappear before your very eyes
first I'll need a volunteer from the
audience
nice try here axe over but you may win
this time well this stinks
[Music]
yeah show's over hey Juan